- You look so freaking cute.
- Thank you.
- Like beautiful, all the
things, the nail game with it.
- It's got pockets.
- Yeah, the nail game makes it
a little more rock and roll.
I don't even wear a dress
without pockets anymore.
I don't have time for that designer.
- No.
- Yeah, I love a pocket.
- Always need your things on you.
- Yes, did you have one
in your wedding dress?
- I did.
- 'Cause congrats, you had pockets?
- I had pockets.
- [Kelly] I love it.
Congrats on your wedding.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's so awesome.
- [Sarah] It was so fun.
- [Kelly] I love your
"Modern Family" costar,
Jesse Tyler Ferguson.
He married y'all, right?
- [Sarah] Yeah, he did.
- [Kelly] Was that the
plan the whole time?
- [Sarah] So, Ty Burrell was originally
supposed to marry us.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Sarah] He's already
ordained to be an officiant.
I don't wanna really say minister.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, he was supposed to
and there was an emergency,
he wasn't able to make it.
Like a week before the
wedding, we found out.
And so, I sent a text message to Jesse,
and 'cause we're obviously
very, very close.
- Yeah.
- And, I was like...
- Please
- Fake TV Uncle, real life
friend, Tony Award winning,
Jesse Tyler Ferguson,
- [Kelly] You can do this.
- will you marry us?
- Yeah.
- And, he so graciously
did it, and amazing.
- Did he have to get
ordained like really fast?
- Yeah, we did this crazy process online,
he got ordained.
- Yeah.
- And the entire wedding,
he kept flashing people his clergy badge.
He was wearing it.
- It's real.
- On the inside, like, look at me.
- I love that.
Is it true that you
threatened your husband
if he didn't cry at your wedding?
- Yes, yes.
- You wanted real emotion.
You wanted to go there, deep.
- I actually specifically verbatim said,
if I don't see you crying
when I walk down the aisle,
I'm turning around.
- [Kelly] Oh, and he did.
- [Sarah] And, he did cry.
- [Kelly] Aww.
I love that.